[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
April 12th I'm J.R Wellen for the Wall
Street Journal
your credit card bill likely has a
recurring charge from a subscription you
might have forgotten you even had now
more Americans are taking a closer look
at those charges and canceling their
subscriptions Wall Street Journal
reporter Rachel wolf joins us with more
hey Rachel thanks for being with us
thanks so much for having me on so
Rachel why have people built up so many
subscriptions we really reached Peak
subscription during the pandemic when
everybody was at home think streaming
think boxes of stuff delivered to your
door so the number of new subscriptions
per user peaked in the third quarter of
2022 that means streaming services
digital memberships food of the month
clubs etc etc since then cancellations
are actually outpacing new subscriptions
according to financial planning app
Rocket money so in other words we've
really reached Peak subscription and now
we're coming down off of a high so
what's caused people to take a closer
look at the money they're spending on
subscriptions household budgets are
getting a lot tighter we have inflation
other economic uncertainties like a
cooling job market I spoke to one man in
Ohio who's canceling subscriptions to
all sorts of things to free up money for
groceries so that he doesn't have to
Penny Pinch at the grocery store by
cutting satellite radio magazines he
never read and going to restaurants
instead of paying for a pricey
membership to a country club he found
that he's not actually having to cut
back that much in other areas
so about a third of people who responded
to a Credit Karma survey said that their
biggest Financial mistake last year was
paying for services they never used
which I know I can relate to but
cancellations for premium streaming
services in the US which includes
Netflix Hulu and HBO Max we're up 49 in
2022 from the previous year according to
subscriber measurement company antenna
you know a lot of us have recurring
monthly fees we pay for various Services
why is it so easy for us to lose track
of what we're paying for so a lot of
people have their subscriptions sent to
auto payment where they just have a
little bit of money coming out of their
accounts between going to get coffee or
a donut going out for drinks streaming
service will just slip right in but now
people are really taking a closer look
at their monthly spending and they're
realizing they're paying about 133
dollars more than they thought they were
so people estimated they were paying
only 86 dollars a month for various
subscriptions really they're paying over
two hundred dollars a month wow and
these subscription charges are just
another in the list of expenses that
people have to contend with are there
services or tools that can help them
manage these recurring payments so there
are a few different subscription
management apps I spoke to the
co-founder of one called scribe up
that's a newer service and they do
something unusual where they give users
a digital credit card to use only for
recurring payments so you've got a
credit card number that you fill in for
say hello fresh meal subscriptions and
what scriber will do is automatically
cancel the subscription after a free
trial instead of waiting to see whether
or not you remember the same service
found that over 50 percent of people had
forgotten to cancel a free trial so
knowing that they wait for people to say
that they want to continue rather than
assuming that they'll remember
you know Rachel it should be easy enough
for people to cancel subscriptions but
some companies make it difficult for
consumers to do that so I spoke to one
consumer who didn't realize she was
paying for class pass for about five
years without really ever using it and
so she ended up spending over five
thousand dollars on the subscription
that she never used she said she wasn't
able to get the money back when she
reached out to them which she was very
disappointed by and she expected class
pass to let her know that they were
going to keep charging her rather than
just assuming that she would remember to
cancel so I was able to get a comment
from class pass and classpass said that
one member sign up they're notified that
their memberships automatically Renew on
the same day each month and they added
that class pass does send reminders when
members have not used their accounts to
book classes but a new proposal from the
Federal Trade Commission could make it
even simpler to break up with your
subscriptions the consumer Watchdog
actually wants to require Merchants to
allow for online cancellation and to get
consent before presenting customers with
retention offers wow but still that's
five thousand dollars that consumer
racked up are they able to get that
money back unfortunately not well no
doubt some consumers have a negative
feeling about subscriptions and the
recurring charges what are companies
doing to get ahead of that that would
reflect the negative sentiment some
companies are shifting their business
model to meet changing consumer feelings
about subscriptions BarkBox which
provides a monthly package of dog treats
and toys is one of them the company
recently laid off 12 percent of its
staff and said it would invest more in
non-subscription products including
treats and other consumables after
weaker than predicted earnings
hellofresh a grocery delivery service
also expects its number of active
customers to decline in the first half
of 2023 after dropping to 7.1 million in
the fourth quarter of 2022 from 8
million in the third quarter so you can
see that these companies are trying new
things they had been on a subscription
high for so long there was a real
subscription Mania now consumers aren't
just willing to keep subscribing and not
looking at their bills they're thinking
harder and realizing that they may not
actually need these things all right
that's Wall Street Journal reporter
Rachel wolf with us Rachel thanks so
much for being with us thanks so much
for having me and that's your money
briefing I'm Jay for the Wall Street
Journal
[Music]